let r be the region enclosed by y is
equal to four times the square root of
nine minus x and the axes in the first
quadrant and we can see that region r
and gray right over here
region r is the base of a solid for each
y value the cross section of the solid
taken perpendicular to the y axis is a
rectangle whose base lies in r and whose
height is y
express the volume of the solid with a
definite integral so pause this video
and see if you can do that
all right now let's do this together and
first let's just try to visualize the
solid and i'll try to do it by drawing
drawing this with a little bit of
perspective so if that's our y-axis
and then
this is
our x-axis
right over here and i can redraw a
region r it looks something like
this
and now let's just imagine a cross
section of our solid so it says the
cross section solid taken perpendicular
to the y axis so let's pick a y value
right over here we're going to go
perpendicular to the y axis it says
whose base lies in r so the base would
look like that it would actually be the
x value that corresponds to that
particular y value so i'll just write x
right over here and then the height is y
so the height
is going to be whatever our y value is
and then if we wanted to calculate the
volume of just a little bit a slice that
has an infinitesimal depth
we could think about that infinitesimal
depth in terms of y
so we could say its depth right over
here
is d y
d y and we could draw other cross
sections for example right over here our
y is much lower it might look some so
our height will be like that but then
our base is
the corresponding x value that sits on
the curve right over that x y pair that
would sit on that curve and so this
cross section would look like this
and once again if we wanted to put if we
wanted to calculate its volume we could
say there's an infinitesimal volume and
it would have depth d y
and so as we've learned many times in
integration what we want to do is think
about the volume of one of these i guess
you could say slices and then integrate
across all of them now there's a couple
of ways to approach it you could try to
integrate with respect to x or you could
integrate with respect to y i'm going to
argue it's much easier to integrate with
respect to y here because we already
have things in terms of d y the volume
of this little slice is going to be y
times x
times d y
now if we want to integrate with respect
to y we want everything in terms of y
and so what we need to do is express x
in terms of y so here we just have to
solve for x so one way to do this is
let's see we can square both sides of
actually let's divide both sides by 4 so
you get y over 4 is equal to the square
root of 9 minus x now we can square both
sides y squared over 16 is equal to 9
minus x
and then let's see we could
multiply both sides by negative 1. so
negative y squared over 16 is equal to x
minus 9 and now we could add 9 to both
sides and we get 9 minus y squared over
16 is equal to x and so we could
substitute that right over there so
another way to express the volume of
this little slice right over here of
infinitesimal depth d y depth is going
to be y
times
9 minus y squared over 16 d y and if we
want to find the volume of the whole
figure that's going to look something
like
something
like that we're just going to integrate
from
y equals 0 to y is equal to 12. so
integrate from y is equal to 0 to y is
equal to 12.
and that's all they asked us to do to
express the volume as a definite
integral but this is actually a definite
integral that you could solve without a
calculator if you if you multiply both
of these terms by y well then you're
just going to have a polynomial in terms
of y and we know how to take the
antiderivative of that and then evaluate
a definite integral